you know one thing i wanted to mention
i'm going to use my hands
because that's something people do
sometimes on television and these days
you need to remind yourself that this is
being televised
one thing i wanted to mention uh my
conan without borders travel specials
are now streaming
on hbo max i really love doing these
specials
uh i visit places like australia
greenland japan armenia
here's a clip from my trip to ghana
no no passion for it for me you don't
want a lot of passion
no no pat oh what's that if i eat the
passion fruit i'll get
a lot of passion get a lot of passion
a lot of energy if i eat the passion
fruits
my wife will be happy very happy because
i'll have the energy
yeah yeah round round round every place
every corner
yeah oh a chase i don't chase my chase
my wife around the corner
no but i'll it'll it'll be good for me
like either oh i can carry my wife if i
eat the passion i want
passion fruit i want all of them if you
eat fashion you'll get a good and sexy
night a good sexy night
i've been buying pills through the mail
[Applause]
it's a lot of fun so make sure to check
out conan without borders now
on hbo max